il s'appelle philippe charles il est
maître de conférences en médecine légale
rattaché à l'ufr des sciences de la
santé à montigny le bretonneux et nous
allons parler avec lui d'un coeur mais
pas n'importe quel coeur celui de
richard coeur de lion près de 800 ans
donc après la mort de richard 1er
d'angleterre
les restes de son corps embaumé ont fait
l'objet d'une analyse biomédicale et
justement nous avons un vrai celui qui
s'est occupé de cette analyse philippe
charlier on l'a rencontré jeudi dernier
lors d'une conférence de presse il nous
a expliqué ses recherches et surtout les
résultats de ses recherches ses plus
importants on l'écouté film sur les bons
jours je vais maître de conférences en
médecine légale du chu raymond poincaré
rattaché ici à l'ufr de sciences à
montigny-le-bretonneux et on va parler
de coeur avec vous en tout cas le coeur
de richard coeur de lion que ça vous
allait étudier le coeur le embaumé le
plus ancien de france alors écrit kim
déjà comment vous allez travailler sur
ce choeur on a utilisé des techniques
qui sont directement médico légal et
anthropologique ce sont les mêmes études
comme leurs effets sur des traces ou sur
des cadavres retrouvés à l'état morcelé
dans une voiture ou dans une forêt donc
c'est exactement le même type de détenus
à prendre pour quelques heures comme ça
non aucune précaution particulière on
avait toujours de contaminer
l'échantillon et on a travaillé sur deux
graves c'est-à-dire vraiment des
fifrelins parce qu'il ne fallait pas
détruire ces restes et également parce
que ce sont des restes humains donc il
s'agissait pas de les abîmer ou les
morceaux les ce sont des restes qui sont
pas que harkat logique c'est aussi une
personne humaine ou ce qu'il en reste
car ces restes ont été découverts en
1838 1 dans une boîte en plomb et
pourquoi avoir attendu aussi longtemps
pour à les étudier
je n'en ai pas la moindre idée en tout
cas on a bénéficié de la bonne grâce si
je peux dire et de l'ouverture d'esprit
des conservateurs du musée
départemental d'archéologie d'oran qui
évidemment était tout à fait heureux de
pouvoir faire vivre ces restes là et
d'en extirper le maximum de
connaissances
une fois que j'ai quand même senti une
certaine émotion non aucune
absolument aucune relation avec un comme
à chaque fois jamais jamais d'émotion
particulière non pas parce que les
médecins légistes n'ont pas d'émotions
loin s'en faut mais tout simplement
parce qu'on a notre froideur
scientifique de base notre détachement
scientifique donc non c'est pour moi
c'est un patient comme les autres
captation comme les autres richard
fisher premier jardin philippe charles
d'angleterre
qu'est-ce que vous avez découvert les
méthodes d'embaumement et ses méthodes
un peu particulières
c'est une technique très original qui
combine à la fois des minéraux en
l'occurrence du mercure est aussi de la
chaux pour déshydrater les pierres et
ensuite des choses qui font que le coeur
sentent bon et qu'il a une odeur qui se
rapproche et l'odeur de sainteté en
l'occurrence de la myrte de la menthe
également un petit peu de campanules un
petit peu de des végétaux qui font que
ça sent très bon et surtout de lens en
grande quantité et du coup il s'agissait
de faire un coeur qui se rapprochent au
maximum de l'odeur de sainteté parce que
ce roi était très décrié ou non de son
déchet en 1999 il avait mené la
troisième croisade contre saladin il
avait eu un comportement assez excessif
pour pas dire cruel contre les juifs les
musulmans et aussi quelques chrétiens
qui ne suivaient pas tout à fait ses
oeuvres donc l'évêque de rochester a
considéré à l'époque
n'irait probablement pas tout de suite
au paradis qui devrait passer trente
trois ans au purgatoire et pour lutter
contre pour minorer cette durée de
transit si je peux dire avant d'arriver
au paradis mais il a fallu utiliser des
aromates très particulier et extrêmement
originaux peut être efficace puisque ça
je ne peux pas l'hiver non mais les
aromates c'est particulier celles
habituellement utilisées à roma pour
l'embaumement c'était l'habitude que les
coeurs soit embaumé à cette période là
en utilisant des choses qui sentent bon
et qu'il ya une sépulture de coeur une
sépulture de viscères d'entrailles une
sépulture de coeur et pouvait même
parfois y avoir une sculpture de cerveau
ou d'autres choses
donc oui cette partition décor et 7
embaumement il est assez spécifique de
la période
ils se retrouvent encore au 19e siècle
donc c'est quelque chose qui a fait
florès qui était assez détesté du
vatican des autorités ecclésiastiques
puisqu'un petit peu plus tard une
boniface suit un cycle après décrété une
bulle qui s'opposaient à cette partition
du corps mais qui était assez peu
efficace
on vous dit c'est normal tu dois faire
penser nous dira un peu de sainteté
c'est à dire que les aromates qui sont
spécifiques ou que le royaume guerre des
rois lançant on le retrouve vraiment
dans des moments christique s'élançant
il est présent au début de la vie du
christ il est apporté par un des trois
rois mages qui se retrouve à la fin
quand harry mathy vient faire le
l'embaumement externe du christ donc et
en plus cette épice ou 7 aromates
lançant jamais été retrouvés jusqu'à
présent dans d'autres abonnements
occidentaux donc il est vraiment réservé
soit des individus extrêmement précieux
extrêmement important sur le plan du
statut soit à l'élite absolue et en
l'occurrence des personnages chrétiens
tractations et dans la façon de faire
purement technique est ce qu'il ya des
choses et vous avez découvert il envoie
vous servir peut-être aujourd'hui le
sénégal sur le plan technique cette
étude comme toutes les autres qui ont
été menées par par notre groupe sert
vraiment à développer et valider des
techniques d'identification utile de la
médecine égal au lieu de développer
cette technique de les valider sur des
cordes individus qui ont fait don de
leur corps à la science nous on préfère
utiliser des substrats archéologiques ou
historiques parce qu'ils sont très bien
documenté parce qu'il se rapproche
beaucoup de plus de ce sur quoi on
travaille en anthropologie médico légal
et là en l'occurrence c'est bien cette
étude du coeur de richard coeur de lion
se rapproche pour nous de l'étude de
résidus cardiaque ou autres qu'on
pourrait retrouver dans les débris d'un
bâtiment incendié
ou écrasées ou dans les débris d'une
voiture quoi que ce soit voilà comme
quand on a étudié les restes données sur
l on a mis au point une technique de
dosage du mercure dans les cheveux quand
on a travaillé sur des nouveaux dosages
d'or dans les cheveux quand on a
travaillé sur les fausses reliques de
jeanne d'arc on a développé une méthode
d'identification de reste d'apparence
brûlé on a décrit également sur d'autres
restes royaux le fluide de putréfaction
solidifier qui est une nouvelle entité
médico légal qui est extrêmement utile
et qu'il a montré son intérêt pour
diagnostiquer par exemple à partir d'un
crâne que dans vous avez l'impression
qu'il est complètement sac et bien
malgré tout on peut diagnostiquer du
paludisme et d'autres maladies
parasitaires dessus qui nous permettent
de mieux comprendre de quoi venir les
gens donc oui c'est mort anciens d'abord
sont utiles ou vivant et en plus sont
particulièrement utiles à la recherche
scientifique et notamment médico légal
vous savez pas si le coeur de richard
coeur de lion était et est sain et
évasion j'en ai pas la moindre idée
non là on n'a pas étudié non il n'y a
pas de pas de pathologie à la guerre il
est mort à la guerre mais en
l'occurrence aucune pathologie sous
jacente ont été mises en évidence mais
là pour le coup sur deux graves de coeur
c'était pas évident je sais un peu
quelles sont les prochaines études que
vous allez mener alors sans doute
personnage historique d'abord je dois
soutenir la thèse des tic sur le statut
du corps morts et ensuite je finirai de
travailler sur les restes de duc de
bedford gens de lancastre qui est
contemporaine jeanne d'arc et c'est
d'ailleurs lui qui a mené si je peux
dire son nom
sa crémation jusqu'au bout sur le bûcher
toujours de revanche et son corps était
a été retrouvé par le même archéologues
de ville dans les années 1830 à très peu
de distance des restes de richard colvin
qu'est ce qu'on doit vous posez sans
arrêt fille charrier qu'est ce qui donne
envie de faire la médecine légale
l'étudier les morts c'est bien dans le
monde des vivants
voilà ce qui est tentant est intéressant
c'est de faire parler les moeurs d'une
façon cartésienne et de récupérer toutes
les informations qui sont en train de se
perdre
voilà moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
rattraper le temps perdu merci merci
avocats sont terrifiés merci